in about 20 minutes right here on this
stage the top three Republican
candidates in the West Virginia Senate
race will be here in Morgantown for our
first Fox News debate of the election
season voters have one week to dastaan
two to decide here who they will want to
go up against Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin this November and as
correspondent Peter Doocy reports the
candidates each have their own strategy
for winning over voters a Republican
candidate for office came up with a new
nickname that makes the leader of the
Senate sound like the leader of a cartel
one of my goals as US senator will be to
ditch cocaine Mitch
cocaine Mitch is now in a TV ad for
former Colbert and Don Blankenship who
is now bringing McConnell's and laws
into the equation talking about a
shipping company associated with
Transportation Secretary Elaine Chows
family Blankenship scamp says quote the
company was implicated recently in
smuggling cocaine from Colombia to
Europe hidden aboard a company ship
carrying foreign coal was seven million
dollars of cocaine and that is why we've
deemed him cocaine Mitch McConnell has
no comment but McConnell link group has
already spent more than 1.3 million
dollars on ads calling Blankenship a
convicted criminal Blankenship who
recently served a year on a misdemeanor
conviction tied to the deadly Upper Big
Branch mine explosion blames the
conviction on anti coal Obama allies and
believes it will soon be overturned
it'll be reversed before the general s
two reason mr. McConnell's very wrong
1.2 million dollars in Democratic super
PAC money has flowed into this race
mostly in attacks on congressman Kevin
Jenkins who is campaigning to stop an
impeachment they're trying to take me
out to take down President Trump when
tonight's debate starts voters and
states outside West Virginia may not
recognize all the candidates right away
but they'll recognize the names
endorsing Attorney General Patrick
Morrissey Ted Cruz Rand Paul Scott
Walker conservatives are uniting behind
my candidacy because I'm the one that
took on Obama overreach Jenkins he's a
common thread among those names
he's got Ted Cruz who said the most
vicious things about President Trump
these are all Patrick more seasoned
never Trumper network Jenkins and more
as he can settle the score tonight
during the first nationally televised
debate or either are you nervous
you know I think you always have a
little bit of pause but I'm excited
because I think this is a chance to
really frame the issues it's not just
about the nonsense TV ads I just spoke
to Don Blankenship who joked that when a
McConnell ally called him mentally ill
he decided to try to prove it and that's
where cocaine Mitch came from he also
says that there's no nerves about facing
an hour long debate because he once
faced 30 years in jail
Brett should be interesting tonight
Peter thank you